all right so everything you're saying
sort of brings us to the meat of what my
whole show has been about for the last
six seven months which is what's going
on with the left so you're talking about
these leftists that are sort of enabling
the Islamists to go about their business
so I get it so there's the Islamists who
are the the believers I suppose and that
there and they're protecting their
religion they're protecting their
ideology and they want to propagate the
ideology in whatever country they're in
as you're showing right now it's
happening in the UK but then there's
just people on the Left progressives
usually who then as I keep saying
they're the road to hell is paved with
good intentions I think they think in
most cases that they're defending Muslim
people but you are a living breathing
example of how misguided that is correct
absolutely for example the problem that
you see here surrounding you right now
we have been encountering this for the
from 2006/7 the very moment we started
talking about Islam
suddenly the left is jumped in and they
started saying all these things you know
I mentioned earlier and they used to
kind of come up with with the moral
relativism and say that who are you to
criticize what Muslims do or Islam has I
mean they used to come up with even
weird ideas for example if you say
humanism is your value system then who
are you to say humanism is better than
Islamism you know for all we know
Islamism could be better than humanism
and they come up with all these
different fallacy I would say they say
things have been like this so why don't
we not change it and so I think most of
the people on the left I'm not talking
with the Islamists but the the nominal
the white Christian in the United States
that's doing this from the progressive
side do you think their intentions or
pure or are they being totally duped I
can't tell what I mean obviously it's
it's to varying
depending on the person I think some are
just willfully being duped some are
unwilling duped some are trying to do
something good
some actually have bad intentions and
are lining up with the Islamist is it is
it just a big mix of all of that I have
some very wild theories about the whole
of the world and why the real story
about Islam
do not get propagated to the world I
think media has a huge role in this and
we know Saudi Arabia spends billions and
hundreds of billions of dollars in
patronizing certain media firms and
public tribulation firms who then kind
of uses its machinery to progress a
certain kind of message for the audience
and this is where kind of a racial
question comment I might make saying
that you might find it kind of offensive
saying that the white people the white
audience or the you know general average
Americans are not actually being fed the
right information thanks to the media
and that media is owned and paid by the
Islamists and that Islamists have
already employed those media and I think
the left the problem about the left I'm
not saying all the left is bad but the
left that is more vocal is actually
pretending to be the left and then there
I should [ __ ] account curse maybe you
can curse believe me every time this
comes up I want a curse sometimes I do
go ahead so what they want to say about
this is actually a version or kind of a
inhibitor for the rest of the world or
the progressives well the word
progressive is kind of hijacked now
right for people like us when we try to
bring the issues forward and they use
those inhibitors to dampen our voice and
we never get any media in a coverage
because what we say could be so
inflammatory that the the you know the
the status pool the surrounding the isla
use of Islam and there is also another
issue that is quite predominately
problematic here in the UK is about
brushing the whole of the migrant
community with one brush calling them
Muslim for example I belong to
Bangladeshi diaspora mmm-hmm we have a
huge population here I think the largest
immigrant community is Bangladeshi and
then we have some India and some
Pakistani all of our coming from
different background different ethnicity
different culture you know heritage and
everything but in the UK government
along with the left are interested in
crossing us as Muslims I am not freaking
Muslim yeah
Indians majority of the Indians are
Hindu still they are classed as Muslims
and whenever we try to correct this it's
not happening nobody's interested the
right the left everybody seems to be
kind of want to generalize us as Muslims
and that where the politics comes in and
they want to keep it that way for some
strange very strange reason right so
there's so much there so you're talking
about first that there's there's funding
from Saudi Arabia from Qatar you know I
think al Jazeera is the best example of
this because al Jazeera is owned by the
government of Qatar we know guitar is
funding all sorts of terrorist
organizations especially in the Middle
East but all over the world basically
and it's funny because al Jazeera oh no
the the extremist funding is something
that is investigated and brought on to
the public noise but what we don't know
nobody has done any kind of proper
research investigation and I'm kind of
inviting every journalist there is
through you to see if they can do an
investigation on Qatari money or
Islamist money going to Public Relation
firms media firms journalistic you know
big journalists or news outlets how they
get the fund and how that fund is used
to skew the world view for for the rest
of the population nobody has done that
research as far as I know right well I
mean there's no doubt that some of that
exists because if you even
with the case of al-jazeera you know
they opened up al Jazeera America here
it just announced that it's closing
about a month ago and it lost something
like 500 million dollars or something
and whatever but it was interesting to
me that so many of my friends on the
Left made it out to seem like this is
where we're gonna finally get truth in
media our media is pretty bad here I
fully admit that right and our online
media used to be better that's getting
bad too but all these people on the Left
were suddenly saying oh yes we're gonna
get good International and American news
from a news organization funded by the
government of Qatar and they thought
that that was a legitimate thought so
that goes to show how the money and
Saudi Arabia opening madrasahs and
mosques probably I think in the UK too
but certainly in Bangladesh right well
in the UK if you want to erect a mosque
you want you have a project proposal you
know all you need to show that you have
the willingness you go to some donors
suddenly you have 1 million pound in
your pocket to use and that has been the
case for the rest of the world like you
heard Germany Saudi Arabia will not take
one immigrant right but when they arrive
they say we're gonna build 40 mosque for
you do you want it
obviously Germany didn't agree lucky for
them but UK is not so lucky and I think
going back to your comment about Al
Jazeera the biggest evidence of Islamic
money in the American media in my view
is when the clock boy what's his name
add media happen yeah I mean you could
see the hoo-ha that was created for no
good reason and that was to elevate the
the profile and and the discussion of
the discourse there is another example I
saw personally and I didn't like and we
actually from our Atheist Bangladesh
page we we promote them you know we
protested is in in you know the program
run by this South African comedian who
recently replaced Jones Daily Show The
Daily Show
Daily Show suddenly this jovial person
comes in and uses demagoguery to say
apparently he job is privatizing women's
sexuality which is completely a fallacy
I see this meme all well I didn't see
that specifically but this idea that
somehow that's protected giving woman
and ownership of her body even though
she probably didn't get to choose it or
in many niggler laces right this idea
though is propagating all over the left
right now and that that's what they buy
and in UK Guardian ran a exactly the
same thing saying that wearing a hijab
could be the biggest feminist statement
you can make which is completely bonkers
and everybody was infuriated however you
know nobody's nobody's kind of
challenging them I don't know how those
you know placement of of content gets in
in in American media but suddenly people
need to be aware of these this kind of
fooling around yeah so I'm curious I
assume you know Tommy Robinson right or
know of Tommy Robinson unfortunately the
name doesn't ring your bell so he Tommy
Robinson I've had him on the show he was
at one time one of the founders of the
English Defence League he works with
pegida now so even even if you don't
know him specifically I know that I deal
yeah so I'm curious what what do you
think of these organizations in general
because I've argued for a long time now
that these organizations that are most
but most people consider them far right
or really anti-immigrant or that they
have some level of true bigotry or
racism in them that I would argue that
it's the left by not dealing with these
issues honestly that has led to the rise
of these things so I would assume that
at some level you probably have some
agreement with them and then at the same
time that that can't feel very good
right I deal when I hear what they say
say whatever they say if you if you put
it in a pie chart thirty percent of what
they say
I would agree in fact they say exactly
the same thing what I say about Islamism
however then their discussion goes to
words we are white nation in England we
had a white nation we're a Christian
white nation and they raise the flag the
English flag which is not the United
Kingdom's flag which is called a cross
in between and then they suddenly start
talking about how good white they are in
interpreting their their value system
maybe they want to protect their country
from immigrants I can understand that
maybe they want to protect their kind of
livelihood because that immigrants are
kind of bringing in cheap labor and
that's what they're feeling threatened
but my suspicion is that EDL actually
possibly work with the Islamist
themselves in the front they fight
between themselves but I think because
you can see the result the ultimate
result is they feel each other and
that's why the I think that beneficiary
comes in that the Islamists get an
attack from the you know far white right
and then suddenly they show and they're
left then suddenly comes them to protect
the minority and then obviously there is
support for the ideal and for example
there's another party recently in the UK
called you keep another Kingdom
independent party they want to be
independent feeling the same sort of
general people mass mentality I think
that's where same mentality that foils
Trump and Ted Cruz
however the left is not doing anything
good by using the Muslims and that's why
the brushing and using a general brush
comes into play in my view right so what
do we do about that as people everything
that you have said that I know about you
I believe the same things the same
things about secular living and atheism
and free thought and humanism and I
think most of my audience believed in
those same things so what do we do here
if you're the average person in the UK
and you want to help this situation
which i think is worse right now in the
UK than it is in the United States I
still think we're a little bit behind
you on a lot of this stuff what do you
do to help these voices well in in the
UK I think in some respects we are doing
much better than
America for example in the UK there is
no there is no legal issue that helps
for example Christianity or for example
education system or for example I heard
even yesterday that there are I think
rubles are being passed where you know
creationism is being progressed in
certain states and also the transgender
issue about you know somebody can be
fined for you know if they're in England
it's actually the other direction that
there is no such law because the the
because it's a small country there is
not many people and it's got a good
tradition of having a very strong
opinion about these things and the
trajectories towards humanism and also
because it's part of the overall
European Union Europeans are quite good
in human rights and all these things and
they're going towards that I think in
America in some aspects you have free
speech and voice but in some aspects
where you don't have the guard down or
you have the guard down
some things are encroaching in and my
observation about America is that the
legislature the the governments are
heavily owned by I think the the the
people who belong to the do the business
you know mentor no doubt about it no
doubt about it
and they have vested interests in Saudi
Arabia Qatar and Christianity all
together that's why I'm trying to that's
my opinion
is yeah you can't divide between
Christianity and Islam because in front
they may have some sort of friction but
at the back where the actual real need
problems are there is no problem they
kind of will help each other yeah so if
we can get to the if you can get to the
legislature and kind of stop those
things and come towards the right kind
of the light it might help yeah you know
there's so much there because it's like
here in America I have all my friends on
the Left who are screaming and screaming
about Trump and I've done many videos on
why I don't like Trump and I've had some
of his supporters on and they explain
why they like him but I've been to PI I
was at a party a couple weeks ago all
Hollywood left
the LA liberals and they were all
freaking out about Trump and I said guys
the one you really have to fear is Ted
Cruz because he's coming from the
religious side of this you know you mean
like if you're truly a secularist and
all that Trump yeah says a lot of he's a
blowhard and all the reasons that there
are not to like him but Trump I but Cruz
I think actually believes the religious
stuff he's saying that type of demagogue
is always much scarier to me well he's
definitely dishonest and he's a freaking
liar Trump may be a lunatic but I don't
think he lies but when if if you know
Darwin forbids if he goes yeah if he
goes to the office this would be a
disaster because everything he says
about Saudi Arabia everything nothing
will change because the checks and money
that has this huge humongous
relationship with Saudi Arabia will
continue because he actually represents
that sort of people although right now
he's using anti Muslim or anti Muslim in
favor of the people he will not change
it definitely no so that's really
interesting so you think if Trump came
in despite all the this stuff that he's
saying about how he would change
business relationships what he has said
about Islam I mean look Obama was in
Saudi Arabia just in these last couple
of days we know this relationships not
going anywhere so that's sort of
depressing that between Obama and Trump
you're saying Saudi Arabia still got a
stranglehold on us either way I don't
know how much you know about the history
if you have two hours to spend and your
audience go and watch a video called
bitter lake I don't know if you heard
about it's a documentary made by Adam
Smith sorry Adam Curtis is a British
documentary maker and it is so close to
the truth that BBC was afraid to air it
in in the broadcasting media it's in
online you can go and watch it but it's
also on our it is my mother's page or in
YouTube anywhere you can find this shows
you that in 1980s I think surrounding
that area when the Arab war happened
so the arabia suddenly raised the oil
price huge and then whole world crumbled
down and america had to get on his knees
and then beg to saudi arabia for and
that situation has not changed we have
not gone out of the dependence of
dependency of the petro ruler and saudi
arabia still has huge control and that's
why even if america says that because
everybody's going freeloader and
everything that's just media talk but in
reality saudi arabia is nowhere to go
unless we can find clean energy or find
an alternative to it so it's it's really
it's it's depressing when you think
about so we're talking about the oil
stuff which we know we have to get off
just to save our country if for no other
if forgetting being in bed with bad guys
just to save our country aren't the
world right and then you also add in
that saudi arabia is exporting all this
sunni Wahhabi ism all the real
radicalism and we know that 18 of the 21
9/11 hijackers came from there just this
week the Obama administration said that
you know people that have relatives that
they lost in 9/11 wouldn't be able to
sue Saudi Arabia so man there's there's
a lot there I gotta get an expert in
nineteen 1945 President Roosevelt met
the king of Saudi Arabia in a war plane
or warship somewhere and they came into
a pact that Saudi Arabia will sell oil
to America in return America will not do
anything about what Saudi Arabia does
with its money and then its religion
religion not to be touched that was the
agreement that came between Roosevelt
and the Saudis and that agreement still
is intact and that's what is or the core
of the problem lies is that Saudi Arabia
has got tremendous amount of money to
spare and to spread its vicious a hobby
zhim and the whole of Bangladesh the
whole of the bloggers whatever you proxy
in terms of Islam is extremism is is -
that if you can sever that relationship
between Saudi Arabia and America because
we know that America is the most
powerful nation of the world and Saudi
Arabia is actually borrowing that power
and destroying the world and the
people's mind that's all I can say about
about that
yeah it's really crazy all right we got
a wrap up here I mean as you were saying
that I was thinking maybe there is then
some hope in what's happened with Iran
because Saudi Arabia doesn't like them
so maybe that is America exerting some
positive influence kinda am i stretching
there there is some hope because unlike
Saudi Arabia Iran has thousands of years
of history culture in fact Bengali
culture has got a lot of elements from
Iranian however the regime that is
ruling Iran now is as bad as Saudis they
you hand gay people in public they still
have moral police and they are kind of
going towards their nuclear but they
could be a worthy adversary an ally for
America however Saudi Arabia is just a
dog just a wild dog they have my view
all right well listen we could talk so
much more and I absolutely will have you
back on again but give people some hope
I like to end all these things
especially the heavier ones I like to
end them with some hope you had some
horrible it happened in Bangladesh just
in these last few days we've talked
about we've talked about a lot of the
underpinnings in the UK in the u.s. that
are that are sort of depressing when you
think about these things so where's the
hope and all this I I'm still in shock
in the last few days I haven't been able
to actually write anything other than
the usual but in between we we see that
the awareness among general people is
rising they are they're getting
interested to know more about the usual
[ __ ] that is in the media and that's
where I think at some point the world
mentality is gonna come into one place
and that and some sort of it threshold
or dinner tip and then we might see some
sort of a resistance against this Islam
that is encroaching toward the world and
obviously we need to sever the the
connection between the businesses and
the business interest and the financial
system and Saudi Arabia and all all the
support that it gets if we can do that I
think you will see a lot of improvement
and I'm really glad grateful for you
inviting me in your show and I really
forward - you know come come back and
you know talk more about these issues
absolutely I hope we can do it live next
time let's give Faizal another shoutout
for connecting us and I want to thank
our men for joining me on the show and
you can check out his writing at Arif
it's a RI F dot EU